ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
ดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันพุธค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
27 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กรกฎาคม
ปีพตอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศอะไรคะปีคอ
2022 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อ
วานนี้วันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 20 ม 6 เดือน
เดือน
กรกฎาคมปีพตต
ปีพต 2  5  6 ห้าปีคศ
ปีพศษส
2022 ค่ะกะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้อยู่วัน
พฤหัสบดีวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
28 เดือน
เดือน
กรกฎาคมปีพตต
ปีพต 2  5  6 ห้าปีคศ
ปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะค่ะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลากี่อา
กงขา
ตอนนี้เวลา
03:00 น
03:00 นกี่นาที
3:00 น 30 นาทีค่ะนึกว่า 3
3 ครูฟ้าตีสามแล้วรูฟ้ายังไม่นอนเหรอคะ
ครูฟ้ายังไม่นอนค่ะครูหญิง
ทำไม้ตีสามเนี่ยครูฟ้าเนี่ยต้องอยู่ที่
นี่แล้วนะคะอยู่ที่เตียงร้อนแล้วก็นอน
ก็นอนแล้วก็น้ำลายไหล
นอนตี 3 เนี่ยครูฟ้าต้องนอนแล้วนะ
ครูฟ้า
นอนไม่หลับ
เอา
แมวมาพวกมันมีเพลงนะฮะแต่ว่านอนไม่หลับก็
คือ
ขอโทษค่ะเดี๋ยวนักเรียนฟังไม่รู้เรื่อง
ครูหญิงจะบอกว่าครูฟ้าไม่ต้อง
ขออนุญาตของเลย
ไม่ต้องร้องเพลง
ทำไมป้านอนไม่หลับนอนหลับนอนนักเรียนอะไร
หินสีฟ้าร้องเพลงเนี่ยครูหญิงก็จะนอนไม่
หลับเหมือนกันได้ยินคุยเนี่ยกำลังจะนอนก็
ได้ยินเสียงครูฟ้าร้องเก่งจริงๆจะหลับ
แล้ว
ร้องเพลงคะ
เลยแล้วก็แบบ
ติ๊กต๊อกติ๊กอดนอนไม่หลับเลย
นักเรียนรู้คือสุดแต่ว่าครูฟ้าแต่
10:00 นง็ 4 ทุ่มเนี่ยครูฟ้าก็เข้านอน
สาธุ
สมัยขอ 11:00 นกับเทียงคืน
ดี 1 ตี 2 ก็คือป่าเนี่ยเข้านอนตั้งแต่
22:00 น 23:00 น 24:00 จังแบบ
หัวนอนตาค้าง
ก็คือนอนไม่หลับเนี่ยหนูครูฟ้าแล้วปกติ
เนี่ยทุกวันทุกวันนะคะวันจันทร์
วันอังคารเนี่ยวันพุธวันพฤหัสวันศุกร์วัน
เสาร์วันอาทิตย์ทุกวันเนี่ยปกติฟ้านอนไม่
หลับทุกวันไหมว่าไม่หาผู้หญิงปกติฟ้าแน่
นอนหลับ
เอ้าแล้วทำไมวันนี้ครูฟ้าดอนไม่หลับล่ะคะ
ครูฝานหนวกหู
หนวกหูอะไรมีเสียง
เสียงเป็นไงฟ้า
เสียงดังอ่ะเสียงดังหมอ
มีเสียงทองเหรอคะใช่หาผู้หญิงมีเสียงดัง
แล้วครูบางคนหนูหนูหนูๆ
ปิดหูแล้วก็ยังนอนไม่หลับ
ใช่แล้วเงิน
เสียงอะไรเสียงอะไรที่ทำให้ครูฟ้าเนี่ย
นอนไม่หลับคะ
เสียงผู้หญิงอ่ะมี
เสียงผู้หญิง
ทำไมอ่ะครูฟ้าเปิดวีดีโอช่องคอมพรีเฮนสิ
เบิ้ลไทยแล้วก็มีเสียงผู้หญิงพูดในวีดีโอ
หรอคะ
เป็นผู้หญิงเขาให้นอนไม่หลับล่ะคะไม่นะ
ช่วยมั้ยนะผู้หญิงเสียใจนะครูฟ้า
จริงๆแล้วนะผู้หญิง
เสียงอะไรอ่ะที่ทำให้ครูฟ้าแน่นอนไม่หลับ
4 เสียง
อันนี้ค่ะ
เสียงอะไรคะครูปลาร้า
ไม่ม่นี้ก่อนก่อนเพลงก็แม็กซ์ไม่มีเสียง
นะคะแต่ว่าน
คะแล้วก็มี
โอ๊ยมานอนสีเหลืองฟ้า
ผ่าเหรอคะใช่ค่ะผู้หญิงเสียงฟ้าผ่า
เปรี้ยง
เปรี้ยงเที่ยง
ก่อตอนนี้ที่บ้านครูฟ้าเนี่ยฝนตก
ใช่ไหมใช่ๆตกฝนตกฝรั่ง
มันก็มีฟ้าผ่าหอก็เลยทำให้เสียงฟ้าผ่าทำ
ให้ครูฟ้าเนี่ยนอนไม่หลับนอนไม่หลับนี่นะ
นอน
ไม่ได้ยินเสียง
เสียงฟ้าผ่า
น้องเออผู้หญิงก็คิดว่าตอนนี้ใช่ไหมตอน
นี้ที่ที่ประเทศไทยนะคะประเทศไทยเนี่ย
เป็นฤดูฝนเนาะฝนแต่ทุกวันนี้ทุกวันใช่ไหม
คิดว่าคนไทยตอนนี้เนี่ยพอได้ยินเสียงฟ้า
ผ่าก็คงนอนไม่หลับเหมือนครูฟ้าแบบตกใจ
สมัยเสียงดังหนึ่งหนวกหู
ผู้หญิงใช่แต่ว่าครูฟ้าคนไทยเนี่ยมีมีผู้
ชายไทยใช่ไหมคะผู้หญิงไทยแหละประมาณ
65 ไหม
65 ล้านคน
65 ล้านคนเนี้ยคิดว่าไม่ใช่ทุกคนที่ได้
ยินเสียงฟ้าผ่าแล้วนอนไม่หลับ
เอางูแล้วคนอื่นจะนอนไม่หลับ
ฮะคนอื่นจะนอนไม่หลับเพราะอะไรเออเพราะ
เสียงอะไรใช่ไหมได้ยินเสียงอะไรแล้วนอน
ไม่หลับ
เอางูลูกอ่ามันมีคนเนี่ยไปถามใช่ไหมคะมี
คำถามแล้วก็ไปถามคนไทยเนี่ยอาจจะไม่ถึง 65
ล้านคนหรอกนะแล้วก็ไปถามคนไทยผู้ชายไทย
ผู้หญิงไทยอาจจะซักประมาณ
100 คนไว้อ้า 100 คน 100 คนว่า x คนไทย
100 คนเนี่ยได้ยินเสียงอะไรแล้วทำให้นอน
ไม่หลับ
มั้ยอ่ารูหญิงเนี่ยรู้แล้วแต่ครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ไม่รู้
วุ้ย R  crew หญิงก็เลยจะมาถามครูฝาผู้
หญิงจะมีให้ทั้งหมด
1  2  3  4  5  6  7
7 ทั้งหมด 7 เสียงเสียงที่
1  2  3  4
5  6 แล้วก็เจ็บ 7 เสียงครูฟ้าคิดว่าคน
ไทย 100 คนเนี่ยนะคะบอกว่าเสียงอะไรที่
ได้ยินแล้วทำให้นอนไม่หลับเนี่ยมาที่สุด
มากที่สุดใส่ค่ะอ่ะเสียงชื่อหนึ่ง
ครูฟ้าคิดว่า
ไม่ใช่เรื่อง
เกินคู่ฟ้าตอบดีกว่าเอ่อจะไปกินละเสียง
อะไรไฟฟ้าคิดว่า
เสียง
กรนเป็นคนเป็นยังไง
ไม่นอนน่ะ
อ้ะเดี๋ยวนะว่าผิดอ่ะ
ก็
นอนอยู่ด้วยกันหรอ
ใช่
เสียงเพราะ
เสียงกรนใช่ไหมคะครูฟ้าอ่ะเสียงกรนแล้วก็
มีผู้หญิงเนี่ยแน่นอนไม่หลับ
สาเสียงกรนครูบาคิดว่าเสียงกรนใช่ไหม
เสียงกรนขอให้
เสียงกรนเสียงกรนแน่นะคะ
ใช่ค่ะมี
เย้ดีเลยนะอันดับที่หนึ่งเลยนะเสียงกรน
เนี่ยมีคนตอบ 29 คน 29 เปอร์เซ็นต์เลยนะ
ที่บอกว่าได้ยินเสียงกรนแล้วนอนไม่หลับ
แล้วครูคิดว่ามีเสียงอะไรอีก
อุบายคิดว่ามีเสียงอันนี้ค่ะนักเรียนมี
เสียงอะไรคะ
หมา
สิเขามาก
เสียงหมาเห่าหอมหมามันเห่าเสียงดังเนี่ย
หนวกหูใช่ไหมนอนไม่หลับนอนไม่หลับหนวกหู
เสียงหมาเห่า
เพลงฟ้า
รู้หรือเปล่าคะเสียงหมาเห่าเนี่ยอยู่
อันดับที่ 2 เลยนะยี่สิบสี่คนบอกว่าได้
ยินเสียงหมาเห่าหรือว่าเสียงแมว
แมวแมวร้องใช่ไหมเนี่ย
น่าจะตัดนะคะแมวร้องอย่างเงี้ยทำให้นอน
ไม่หลับเก่งมากแล้วกูก็ที่ว่ามีเสียงอะไร
หรือ
ว่าคิดว่าเสียง
นิเสียงอะไรคะ
ก็เห็นหรอคะ
เห็นอะไรคะเราไม่เห็นเนาะไม่เห็นไม่เห็น
อ้ะเค้าคิดว่าเสียงรถใช่ไหมเวลารถขับมา
วดีเสียงแตรๆๆ
เออหรือว่าจะเป็นเสียงรถที่ขับแล้วก็แบบ
Break อ่ะ
จะยะก็เสียงดังทำให้นอนไม่หลับใช่
รักผู้หญิงเสียงรถหากว่าคิดว่า
มี 5 หูฟ้าคุณรู้ได้ไงคะ
เสี่ยงรถอยู่อันดับที่ 3 เลยนะมี 15 คน 15
เปอร์เซ็นต์ที่บอกว่าเสียงรถเนี่ยทำให้
นอนไม่หลับ
ไหลลงมาเลยอะไรอีกถ้าเจอไล่กันมาเลยความ
รู้ได้ยังไงคะคือป๊า
ก็ไม่รู้นะฮะต่อไปหนูไม่จะมีคนเรามันจะมี
เสียงอะไรอ่ะมี 7 เสียงนะที่คนไทยต่อบ้าง
ว่าทำให้นอนไม่หลับ
4 เสียง
ทีวีหรือเปล่า
เสียงทีวีใช่ไหมคะอย่างดี
อ้าเนี่ยนักเรียนสิ่งทีวีสายๆ
ก็เลือกหนึ่งค่ะ
อ้าวเสียงทีวีก็ได้อ่ะเสียงทีวีใช่ไหม
เสียงทีวีเนี่ยมีค่า
งานไม่ได้อยู่อันดับที่ 4 นะสิ่งทีวี
เนี่ยอยู่อันดับที่ 5 มี 6 เปอร์เซ็นต์นะ
ที่บอกว่าเสียงทีวีทำให้นอนไม่หลับก็ครู
ฟ้าบอกว่าเสียงเพลงก็จะไม่เสียงเพลง
นึงเลยครูฟ้าร้องเพลงเสียงเต้นเนี่ยผู้
หญิงนอนไม่หลับหรืออาจจะเป็นเสียงเพลงแบบ
สุ่มๆ
ใช่ไหมเสียงดังๆอ่ะอ่าเสียงดีเสียงเพลงก็
มีค่ะครูฟ้า
จริงหรอในการจำเเนกทรายค่ะอ่าหรืออีก 2
เสียงครูฟ้ากินว่าอันดับที่ 4 กับอันดับ
ที่เจ็ดเนี่ยเสียงอะไรที่แบบทำให้เรา
เนี่ยนอนไม่หลับ
เสียงเพื่อนบ้านมั้ยอ๋อเออแต่ว่ามีบ้าน
นางนอนอยู่ใช่ไหมค่ะน้องยินเสียงเพื่อน
บ้าน
เขาจะดังนี้กันเหมือนจะคุยกันอาจจะมี
ปาร์ตี้หรือว่าแบบทะเลาะกันไปนะทำให้
เพื่อนแถวบ้านตอนอย่าทะเลาะ
เสียงเพื่อนบ้านสมัยแต่ว่าถ้าสมมติอย่าง
ครูหญิงผู้หญิงอยู่คอนโดมิเนียมสมัยห้อง
ที่ 1 ห้องที่ 2 อันนี้ห้องผู้หญิงก็อาจ
จะเป็นเสียงข้างห้องข้างห้องเสียงดังนะคะ
ก็ทำให้นอนไม่หลับมีค่ะครูค้าอันดับที่ 4
เลยนะมีคน 10% นะที่บอกว่าเสียงเพื่อน
บ้านเสียงข้างห้องเนี่ยทำให้นอนไม่หลับ
อ่ะเสียงสุดท้ายครูฟ้าคิดว่าเสียงอะไร
มาคิดอันนี้มานั้นไม่รู้ว่าจะมีไหมเนี่ย
ลูกค้ากูมาเนี่ยนอนไม่หลับเพราะอย่างนี้
บ่อยๆ
เสียงอะไรคะ
เสียงซ่อม
ซ่อมบ้านชั้นครึ่ง
ดีหรือว่าเห็นเด็กหรือเสียงแบบเอง
เสียงจอกเสียงแบบบางทีมีผนังใช่ไหมแล้วก็
เจาะเสียงจอกนะคะอ่าอะไร
ไม่มีค่า
ไม่ใช่มั้ยใช่ครูฟ้าเสียงที่ 7 เดี๋ยวนะ
คะมันจะคล้ายคล้ายๆกับเสียงที่หนึ่งเสียง
ที่ 1 เนี่ยเสียงกรนก็คือจับคนสวยครูฟ้า
นอนครูหญิงนอนแล้วก็ครูหญิงเนี่ยกรน
นอนไม่ได้นอนให้หลับเสียงที่เจ็ดเนี่ย
คล้ายๆเสียงกรนมาจากคนเขียนกันคุณคิดอะไร
ดีอิอิ
บอกว่าเสียงตดก็
ก็บ่แต่ถ้านักเรียน
อันนี้เราเป็นคนใช่ไหมแล้วเราก็ยืนนี้
ข้างหน้านะแล้วก็ข้างหลังนะคะแล้วก็
พูดเสียงตดไม่ใช่สิ
ถ้าซื้อ
เสียงคนเรานอนแล้วก็
กรนตลอดเวลาไม่มีใครตดตลอดเวลานะครับกู
พูดกี่ปีๆที่
ที่มี
เสียงสักเราจักเราจัดปากเหมือนกัน 4
เสียง
กัดฟัน
ยังไงคะเสียงจับปั่นไม่ชอบ
ตอนดังเสียงกับฟันไหนปั่นแล้วก็เออ
เสียงกัดฟันไปบางคนนอนแล้วก็เนี่ยฟันฟัน
บนแล้วก็ฟันล่างสีฟันบนซ้ายนะคะแล้วก็คือ
มีเสียงกัดฟัน
ใหญ่อันดับสุดท้าย
3% นะคะ 3% ที่บอกว่าเป็นเสียงกัดฟันนะ
คะอะผู้หญิงมีคำถามอีกหนึ่งคำถามกูป่าทำ
อะไรทั้งหมดแล้วนะคะอ่ะเสียงกรนเสียงอะไร
นะสิ่งที่ 2 อ่ะตีหยัง
ขอการเสริมโดยมีเสียงกร้อนเสียงหมาเห่า
ข่าวเสียงรถเสียงเพื่อนบ้านเสียงทีวี
เสียงเพลงแล้วก็เสียงกัดฟันนะคะทั้งหมด 7
เสียงนี้เนี่ยสำหรับ
ร้านค้านะเสียงอะไรที่ทำให้กูฟ้าเนี่ยนอน
ไม่หลับหรือว่านอนไม่ได้มากที่สุด
เสียงกัดฟันค่ะโอเคก็ Stop แชร์แล้วนะ
เสียงกัปตันใช่มั้ยเหอะตัน
ก็คือ
หาผู้หญิงนอนจะตัน
ก็คืนนอนไม่ได้เลยถึงไม่ได้ทำให้เป็นนะคะ
อ๋อ
ก็ไม่ชอบเลยเอารักผู้หญิงล่ะครูหญิงหรอ
น่าจะเป็นเสียง
เสียงเสียง 2 อ่ะแต่ผู้หญิงไม่ใช่เสียง
หมาเห่า
น่าจะเสียงแบบแมวร้องแมว
เกิดเมื่อก่อนน่ะที่บ้านครูหญิงมีแมวไง
แล้วเวลากลางคืนน่ะแมวมันจะเดินแล้วมันก็
ร้องนะ
ก็เหมือนเดซิเบลมันเยอะอ่ะตื่นแล้วนอนไม่
ได้เอ้อฟรีคิดว่าเสียงแมวร้องอ่ะใช่มัน
จังหวะกว้างอะนั่นแหละค่ะแล้วนักเรียนล่ะ
คะเสียงไหนที่ทำให้นักเรียนเนี่ยนอนไม่
หลับมันแบบหนวกหูจะไปนอนไม่หลับนะคะมาก
ที่สุดก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้เนาะแต่ว่า
วีดีโอนี้นะคะคุยกับครูฟ้าก็ต้องไปก่อน
แล้วเดี๋ยวเราเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้าสวัสดี
ค่ะอ่ะ